happiness is an inside job what do you
mean by that so I talk about happiness
in the book slightly begrudgingly
because I think we try and convince
people that we should try and be happy
and happiness is the end goal but in
doing so we make lots of people very
unhappy and that's because happiness is
just a deflection from the Baseline M
happiness sadness grief anger jealousy
regret remorse all of these deflections
play a role when I failed to get the
marks I needed to get into med school
first time round I missed out on my
Chemistry aade by two marks my course
work was moderated down um and they
missed out by place at
Liverpool uh the head teacher Rong and
said Alex would be a good student you
know give him a go nope if I was walking
around happy that whole day and smiling
away it'd be pretty weird everyone be
like what is wrong with this guy he's
just lost his place in med school and
also if I was happy all the time I
wouldn't do anything no one does
anything hard or does anything without
feeling there is an urgency to do so
there's an intention to do so if I was
just happy all the time nothing if the
whole human race was happy all the time
nothing would get done there would be
no there'd be no reason like imperative
Initiative for us to do anything that's
Happy defined by like uh hedonistically
Happy rather than you demonically happy
or like yeah I think the word happy is
is weird because it's got so many see I
think that problem is tarnished because
we use as that I think what people mean
is peace I think it's balance
equilibrium right like hemodynamics in
the body like being in a state of of
peace is I think the is the is the goal
this kind of hedonistic I agree with you
absolutely idea of happiness I mean you
know chasing this feeling of like warm
fuzzy feeling all the time just leaves
you to misery and also people then go
well if I'm not happy all the time
there's something wrong with me and that
creates discomfort and discontent and
the opposite of Peace when someone dies
in your family you should feel sad and
grief when something bad happens you
should feel frustration when you want to
achieve something and it feels far away
you want to feel determination and all
that kind of stuff and I think the real
goal is just finding that equilibrium
between everything I think no one should
live in anxiety all the time no one
should feel sad all the time no one
should feel happy all the time you know
we we got to find that balance between
everything and you'll find actually when
you stop chasing happiness as defined by
the hedonistic view of Happiness you'll
actually find that you're much more
content in life you know it's kind of
like with a relationship if you're
looking for a relationship that's full
of Thrills and highs and craziness all
the time this kind of dopamine Rush of
like love all the time you know the
Newton's third law tells us every every
um uh every action has an equal and
opposite reaction of energy so a lot of
the kind of Love Drunk relationships
also have huge lows and huge arguments
and fallouts and so on really you want a
relationship with someone where you're
content you're at peace
you balance each other out and that
generally you move through life in a
synergistic way that's actually what
most people want again in love oh you
should be looking for someone that you
know you can't stop thinking about that
sounds pretty bad doesn't it to me that
doesn't sound like a good relationship
but it's what we're sold so I think
redefining our view of Happiness looking
at it as like I want to feel that in
each day generally have a state of
purpose there's a reason to be that I
get joy out of my day that I'm able to
deal with challenges that I can create
connection with people that I spend a
reasonable amount of time doing things I
enjoy I think that to me sounds like a
good life and just again if in doubt ask
yourself what does a good life look like
to me what does it mean to have a good
life you know when it's the last time
you sat down and thought is this life
that I have the life that I want and if
it isn't what am I doing each day to
work towards the life I do want if
you're just moving constantly and doing
things because the people expect you you
do and it's not essential and you agree
to stuff and don't have boundaries
before you'll know before you know it
you'll end up wherever the river's
taking you you know the river will take
you the way in the direction that it's
flowing and if you allow yourself to
succumb to that you will just follow the
direction of that River you've got to
kind of I think you got to sometimes in
life just stop you got to step out you
got to paddle towards the shore get out
of the river take a moment to have a
look at the direction it's it's heading
in and then decide if that's what what
you want discomfort tells you something
if you're feeling discomfort in your
life it's signal it's like pain we learn
about it don't we pain is telling you
something it's just a message it's just
telling you that there's something
happening youve got to make a decision
if you're going to take your hand out
the fire or not that's your decision but
if you just don't look at your hand
that's burning you're not going to know
what's happening are you you're just
going to kind of carry on it's why it's
like oh well should we like get rid of
pain no we need pain because you need
pain to know otherwise you you don't
know when you're standing leaning on on
the stove hey friends thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed this clip
then click here for the full unedited
episode and if you like that then do
please consider subscribing to the
channel it means a lot thank you so much
and have a great day bye-bye